sources tell CBS News the president is
feeling increased pressure to end the
government shutdown when sources also
insist he's not going to change his
position about funding for our border
wall well yesterday House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi says unless the government opens
this week she is rescinding the
invitation to the President to deliver
his State of the Union address in the
House of Representatives she said you
can do it in writing if you want and
this was all scheduled to take place on
January 29th in the house chamber it has
been a week since the president last
spoke with Democratic leaders and
there's no sign of progress in ending
this 27 day shutdown Paula Reid is at
the White House again this morning Paula
good morning good morning the president
has not responded to speaker Pelosi but
sources inside the White House tell us
that top officials are suggesting to the
president that he should view this
political maneuvering as a sign of
weakness and a suggestion that Democrats
fear that he would use this enormous
platform to his advantage this isn't the
State of the Union is not good
speaker Pelosi wants to delay the
president's annual address to the nation
until after the government reopens
in a letter to the president yesterday
Pelosi citing security concerns argued
both the Secret Service and the
Department of Homeland Security have not
been funded for 26 days now DHS
secretary Kirsten Nielson countered and
said her Department and the u.s. Secret
Service are fully prepared to support
and secure the State of the Union
President Trump responded to Pelosi
Power move with uncharacteristic silence
but lawmakers made plenty of noise
Democrats have made a marketing decision
to obstruct president Trump at all cause
I want President Trump to look into
these faces as Americans increasingly
turn to one another they can grab some
non-perishable goods for the time they
need some help restaurants and food
banks are helping people put food on the
table I mean who can't pass up mac and
cheese but federal workers on the brink
of making tough financial decisions
every day that it lasts it heightens my
anxiety and my level of concern and I'm
definitely feeling the pinch want
Washington to get past politics the
federal work force should not be held
hostage in what could be a continuing
debate and get back to work we need them
to get back to work because they're
messing us up yesterday the President
signed a bill to ensure that furloughed
workers will receive their paychecks
after the shutdown ends but the fact
that both sides of the aisle are arguing
over an event that won't take place for
two weeks suggests that everyone knows
this is unlikely to end anytime soon
John all right Paula read it for us at
the White House thanks Paula